يفرض نمط التسلح المتوفر لدى طرفي الصراع
في السودان التحرك الميدانيه والتكتيكات
القتاليه التي يتبعانها دون اخفاء لطبيعه
المناطق الجغرافيه التي تدور فيها
الاشتباكات الجيش السوداني ذو التسليح
النظمي الثقيل مع تفوق جوي يعمل على
السيطره بالطرق التقليديه للجيوش اما قوات
الدعم السريع فتتكل على تسليحها الخفيف
الذي يتيح لها تنفيذ عمليات كر وفر في
القتال الدائر يمكن الحديث عن مثلث مشتعل
يسعى كل طرف للسيطره او الحفاظ عليه مثلث
المطارات والموانئ والبقر السياديه
في العاصمه الخرطوم تتركز المواجهات على
ما يصطلح على تسميتها مواقع سياديه او
استراتيجيه القصر الرئاسي وما يعنيه
معنويا من سلطه سياسيه مقر القياده العامه
للجيش ودلالته مقرا اساسيا للقوات المسلحه
مقر التلفزه الرسميه وغيرها العشرات
السيطره على هذه المواقع قد تشي بان ما
يمسك بها لديهم يضد طول ميدنيا في عاصمه
الدوله ومؤسساتها الضلع الثاني في
المعادله المطارات قوات الدعم السريعه
تتحرك نحو مطار مروي وتشتبك مع وحدات من
الجيش لايام قبل ان تنسحب
فالسيطره على المطار تعني حرمان الجيش
السوداني من بعض عناصر تفوقه الجوي اضافه
للحصول على نافذه يمكن استغلالها لاحقا في
اي دعم من وراء الحدود ثم انتقلت قوات
الدعم السريع لمحاوله السيطره على مطار
الخرطوم الذي يضم قاعده عسكريه ايضا لم
تحسم المعركه حوله بعد فجغرافيا المطار
ممتده في منطقه مفتوحه وبالتالي يسهل رصد
اي تحرك هاجمت قوات الدعم السريع ايضا
مطار الاوبيض ذا الموقع استراتيجي الذي
يتوسط العاصمه واقليم دارفور ومنطقه ابيه
الغنيه بالنفط
مطار الفاشر في ولايه شمال دارفور يقع ضمن
مناطق نفوذ واسعه للدعم السريع لكن الجيش
متكلا على تفوقه الجوي بسطه سيطرته عليه
اما مطار نيالا في ولايه جنوب دارفور
فتسيطر عليه قوه الدعم السريع
المعركه على المواقع الاستراتيجيه تشمل
ايضا القتال حول الموانئ التي تعتبر
ضروريه نظرا لسهوله نقل المؤن والمساعدات
العسكريه عبرها وبكميات اكبر مما قد ينقل
جوا
تنتشر على الساحل السوداني موانئ عده
بورسودان اهمها واكبرها اخفقت قوات الدعم
السريع في السيطره عليه ويستخدم حاليا
قاعده اساسيه في اشلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه